as federal investigators work to
determine the cause of the deadly boat
fire off Southern California last week
the community of Santa Barbara came
together to remember the victims a vigil
was held last night to honor the 34
people who were killed when their dive
boat burned while anchored 27 miles off
Santa Barbara the victims came from
around the u.s. and as far away as
Singapore and Japan as Kris Van Cleave
reports efforts are underway to raise
the wreckage from the seafloor strong
winds and currents are creating
treacherous conditions for divers
working the salvage operation on Friday
a team of fire experts from the ATF
joined the investigation the fact the
ATF is participating now is that any
reason to think that this has moved into
more of a criminal investigation we are
looking to determine what happened and a
criminal element to that is always a
possibility but at this point no one has
been charged criminally the fast-moving
flames trapped 34 people below deck the
coroner says it appears some died from
smoke inhalation now for the first time
conceptions owner is speaking out
claiming his captain stayed until the
very last moment at a certain point when
the flames had engulfed the boat and
they were in the water they said they
could see Jerry jump from the upper deck
a long jump and that there was a trail
of smoke following him they thought he
was on fire in interviews with the NTSB
surviving crew members claimed smoke
alarms on Concepcion never went off it's
not hooked up into the wiring into a
system that notifies the bridge that
there's a problem one of the many
questions investigators still have was
anyone on the crew awake the boat was
required to have a roving night watchman
Vicki Moore lost her partner Scott Chan
and her 26 year old daughter both of
them were scientists she posted this
most amazing photographs it's so
important that more people understand
and appreciate the natural world and
they got it and they wanted to impart
that to others too we're learning the
victims come from across California and
around the world for CBS this morning
Saturday Kris Van Cleave Santa Barbara
California